so we recently discussed Saladin in the
context of what I call fake history and
uh we looked at how this Muslim hero who
ejected the Crusaders out of Jerusalem
during the wars between the Muslims and
the Crusaders in 1187 he retook
Jerusalem and many other cities and
almost uh completely ejected the
Crusaders out of the Holy Land entirely
but that's another story at any rate we
looked at how on the one hand he's
portrayed in the west as this Paragon of
virtue clemency moderation or being
moderate moderate Muslim essentially and
uh magnanimity etc etc and we also
looked how on the other hand especially
Muslim sources that were iwitness
accounts by his own men and Were Meant
To Praise Him portray him as basically
Isis on
steroids and uh what I mean by that is
he frequently had Christians cuted under
his rule in Egypt the minorities for
example the cops he had their churches
tarred destroyed he had them crucified
beheaded uh the the the cross of the
Crusaders the True Cross which was the
most prized Relic he had confiscated
dragged into the dirt and Damascus spat
upon and he held it hostage for ransoms
which many Crusader Kings including King
Richard tried to get but they couldn't
and it disappears from history and
enters Legend at that point but he also
uh beheaded Crusaders and Christians who
would not Embrace Islam including at the
Battle of hatson where he beat the
Crusaders in 1187 right before he
conquered Jerusalem the Knights of the
temple and the hospital he gave them the
choice to convert to Islam or die they
refused he had them all had their heads
saw off and in fact the Isis videos that
we see are based on the rendering in the
in the narratives in the Muslim
narratives which I quoted from in the
previous
video and so the question now is all
right if Saladin was as I say this
basically Isis type guy who engaged in
all these violent
atrocities um what I just recapped if he
was that then why did the West pick him
of all Muslim Sultans and leaders and
KHS to heroize and to create this myth
around if what I'm saying is true and
that's obviously an important question
because where did it come from there has
to be some truth there has to be
something thing otherwise if it's just a
complete fabrication any old Muslim
Sultan would do I suppose if they're all
the same the reason that saladan is so
extolled in the western tradition is
simply that he was he wasn't what they
say he wasn't this Paragon of virtue and
magnanimity and tolerance and clemency
Etc but he was better than almost every
other Muslim Sultan that the crusaders
had to deal with and that's it he was
when you compare him to all the other
ones he was definitely a lot better in
what sense he was better in that he kept
his word when he made a treaty with the
Crusaders he kept it he you know and and
that's a far cry as we'll see from what
other Muslim leaders did he kept his
word and also as I spoke in the last
video um he would allow for
example uh old and decrepit Christians
after he would conquer a region such as
Jerusalem Le without Ransom okay so
those are the two main things so to
truly underscore how impressive those
two things were in the eyes of the
Crusaders and their posterity up until
now let's look at another Muslim hero in
the Islamic tradition who's probably the
most Muslim leader compared to Saladin
in fact I would argue he's more popular
in the Middle East in the Islamic world
then Saladin Saladin was never really
that popular amongst Muslims until the
West praised him so much and then they
Muslims followed suit and now they use
him um as an example of how great
Islamic civilization was but actually
other Muslims Muslim leaders such as
nural Dean uh saladin's Master actually
who he betrayed uh in at the very end
he's actually more popular amongst
Muslims and the fellow I'm going to
describe right now so the one I'm going
to talk about now is B bars and um he
was the Sultan of Egypt maybe 70 80
years after Saladin and um he's very
much similar to Saladin in the sense
that both he and saladan were Outsiders
saladan is a kurd uh Byars was a cirian
slave he was part of the mamluk system a
slave soldier in Egypt that were
enslaved by saladan and his descendants
actually and they were forced to convert
to Islam as children and trained to
become Warriors just like the
janissaries in the Ottoman Empire but in
Egypt they're called the mamluk and
mamluk is Arabic for he who is owned at
any rate so this B bars and his crew
eventually uh took over Egypt and they
killed the last of saladin's own
Descendants the aits and they took the
the the throne and the sultanate but
Byars is very much like Saladin because
as I mentioned they're both Outsiders
kurd and mamluke but also he very much
appropriated jihadist propaganda against
the Crusaders just like Saladin did and
then in the sources he comes out as a
very highest Muslim just like Saladin
and just like Saladin he also scored
many victories against the Crusaders and
nearly expelled them entirely from the
holy land and uh which they were
eventually about 20 years after he died
or 15 years also from another mumluk
Egyptian Sultan at any rate to Muslims
he's often called the second Saladin and
he's very much compared now let's look
at his behavior compared to the
Crusaders he was responsible for what's
considered the single worst atrocity in
the entirety of Crusader history from
from its very Beginnings let's say the
conquest of Antioch in
1097 uh until the mamlukes got rid of or
evicted the Crusaders from the Holy Land
in 1291 those are the general uh dates
that are given and Antioch I believe was
sacked in 1268 by him and basically once
they took over that City that stronghold
that Fortress they locked the doors and
engage in what's considered one of the
most orisic blood baths ever in fact he
show you his quality B bars ended up
writing a letter to the Lord of Antioch
who was not there at the time boham and
one of the numbers third fourth fifth I
forget um and let me read the letter to
you so B bars wrote quote you would have
seen your Knights prostrated beneath the
hores Foose your horse is stormed by
pillagers and ran racked by looters your
women sold four at a time and bought for
a dinar of your own money which was
plundered you would have seen the
crosses in your churches broken the
pages of your false Testaments meaning
the Old and New Testament scattered the
Patriarchs tombs overturned you would
have seen your Muslim enemy trampling on
the place where you celebrate your Holy
Mass cutting the throats of monks
priests and deacons upon the altars you
would have seen fire running through
your palaces and your churches your dead
burned and your church is pulled down
and destroyed all right so such is B
bars but
also also unlike
Saladin and this is where he was really
bad but in a way not or rather this is
how saladan was good because what Byars
what I'm going to tell you is what a lot
of Sultans did he continuously broke his
word with the Crusaders so he would
besiege them they'd go to war and then
the time would come and they would
parlay and he would offer them uh
clemency if they uh open their
strongholds and just gave up as as uh as
saladan did with Jerusalem and once they
did he would completely renig on his
word kill them all enslave them etc etc
this happened especially there's two
noteworthy times when this happened but
he did it many times um and it was both
to again the most committed Crusade
Fighters just like Saladin hated them
uh the Knights of the temple and the
hospital in 1265 and in 1266 he did it
to the Fortress of aruf and later
safad Again by the Templars and the
hospitallers and both times they were
besieged and obviously as usual the
Muslims completely outnumbered the
Christians uh because they're on their
own home territory and in both cases
finally because both the hospitallers
and and the Templars had a lot of hold
up Christian civil ions with them who
were suffering and terrified and they
were willing to actually just parlay and
give in and they did and and bayars
promised them they can withdraw in peace
they take their possessions etc etc he
just he's going to take over the
fortresses and when they came out he
completely attacked them he beheaded
them in one case he created a for almost
like a a mongle style pyramid of their
heads about 2,000 Christian heads and
those that he kept he took into slavery
and took back into Egypt and this he did
this many times here for example are the
words of the Templar of tier who was
contemporary with these events and this
is what he wrote about when biars took
safad uh in 1266 he writes quote byar
swore to conduct to conduct them the
Christians in good faith to AER or AER
or AKA in Arabic safe and secure so they
came out of the castle at which point he
had them all seized and conducted some
distance from safad to a small hilock
about half a league away and there he
put them to death beheaded then he had a
circular wall erected around them and
their bones and heads may still be seen
remember he's a
contemporary so therein lies the secret
of the Saladin myth he was better than
that he wasn't a paragon of virtue and
moderation but compared to his
colleagues if you will uh his
contemporaries to other Muslim leaders
Sultans and so forth um yeah he was
pretty good he kept his word uh that's
Noble and uh once in a while he showed
some clemency when it was also
advantageous and made sense for him from
a he was pragmatic he was a very
pragmatic man okay he wasn't out
necessarily cruel and sadistic but he
would do what's needed to also keep the
Muslims uh inspired which included
behaving like a jihadist as we've seen
so he was definitely better but just
because he was better does not make him
a paragon or an example of greatness and
moderation the way he is held today and
I think this just shows how from the
very beginning Christians and up until
now westerners Etc are dying desperately
to find something good someone good in
Islam so when they find that which is
better the better becomes great okay but
the reality is if you look at saladin's
times keeping your word a truce a treaty
a pact that you make with your enemy
that was kind of standard especially
amongst Christians in medieval
Christendom sure sometimes they broke it
too but it was expected and there are
countless Crusaders and Kings who kept
their words to one another and to the
Muslims but you don't remember them
because of that you don't hear about it
because that's expected that's the norm
okay but because when it comes to Islam
you have mostly people acting like B
bars
when you get a guy like Saladin he
becomes so elevated and he looks like
the Exemplar but in reality yeah he was
by by by normal standards he was good he
was good yeah he kept his word but he
also compelled Christians to embrace
Islam or carve their heads off as he did
at the Battle of haton with the Knights
Templars and and hospitallers and as I
mentioned destroy churches etc etc so
when it comes down to it I'm not hating
on Saladin I would much prefer to fall
into saladin's hands than into B bars if
that's worth anything uh but the guy is
not what he's presented as in movies and
in
novels uh you know this great
magnanimous hero he wasn't that
spectacular compared to others to
compare to Christians and Crusaders even
compared to some Mongols but compared to
the jihadist Warlords of his time yeah
he was pretty good
so to be clear I've got nothing against
Saladin I'd much prefer to fall into his
hands and someone like bers who was more
common at that time sh saladan destroyed
churches and enforced Jizzy on
Christians and burned and killed and
crucified the Egyptians under his power
sure he compelled and tried to force the
Knights of the temple in the hospital to
embrace Islam and renounce Christ and
they didn't and he had their heads
carved off sure all that I mean but
that's par for for the course but he did
keep his word with Christians and when
he had a treaty he actually stuck to it
and on occasion when it was pragmatic
and practical for him he let go of old
and decrepit Christians without having
them pay Ransom so that's pretty
impressive but is that enough for him to
be so elevated and presented as this
Paragon of virtue and magnanimity etc
etc I think not